mark your new book a screenwriters
journey to success yes I understand from
what you told me off-camera it took you
five years to actually write did it did
I didn't sat down to write a book
initially I was blogging and I wanted to
get my past 20 years of professional
experience amount out of my you know
mind and heart and try to be able to
share it with people and so after five
or six years of blogging I realized that
I had enough information to you know
create something and so I started the
process of stripping down the articles
and reef fabricating them into you know
into chapters and and then I thought
well I'm gonna chart my journey from how
I started in the business as a filmmaker
at eleven years old you know what what
was that spark that creative spark and
charted all the way until today and not
so much as a memoir but also using
examples and funny anecdotal stories but
you know disciplines that I've used that
have helped me you know stay in the game
that hopefully other other writers would
be able to see and go oh yeah I'm not
doing that or I need to do that well you
referenced a friend's grandfather gave
him a camera when you were both around
eleven and that sparked your love for
making movies together have you ever
thought about what if that hadn't
happened oh yeah I I'm not I'm sure
would have been some I should have I
would have gone into some creative
endeavor I wanted to be a cartoonist
originally because I loved to draw and I
still do and in the book there's um when
I was writing the book I drink a lot of
coffee and so it would leave a coffee
ring you know on the notes and so I
would do little doodles and I've turned
those into coffee ring mugs and t-shirts
and things like that but they're also in
the book after every chapter and so I
wanted to be a cartoonist or an animator
or something creative and but yeah
filmmaking I don't know if he maybe my
parents my parents eventually bought me
my own camera but I don't know you know
it's it's interesting I think about it
that there's the
times in your life that you know it you
only can look back on now but I don't
know it'd be interesting what I would do
something creative absolutely I was not
going to be a doctor you know why not
did that you know I was not gonna have a
day job I was going to do something
creative so I knew that because my
parents were always very supportive of
my brother and myself in the creative
arts and my brother is a graphic
designer
and you know he's always had the ability
and talent for art and so my parents my
dad wanted to be a singer and he came
out to Los Angeles from Michigan in the
early 60s and he would sing in the piano
bars and he recorded you know little 45
records you know and he wanted to be a
singer and that was his creative thing
but I always saw him doing poetry and
and drawing and you know things like
that and my mom was artistically
inclined with jewelry making and so I
came from creative parents but they came
from an era where their parents didn't
support them you were gonna get a job in
business or you were gonna go in a
factory it was just very clear-cut and
so I think they wanted to break that
mold and really supported my brother and
I for that and that's so important and I
in the book dedicate the book to my
parents because without them there would
be no support system you know I mean
that's vital I think that's that's
beautiful
you